io sono una neurologa e mi occupo di
neuroimmagini ossia di tecniche di
mappatura del cervello umano
prevalentemente di risonanza magnetica
per studiare le malattie neurologiche ed
in particolare la sclerosi multipla
immaginiamo una ragazza a cui sia stato
appena diagnosticata una malattia è una
malattia che colpisce prevalentemente i
giovani adulti in circa 5 casi su dieci
porterà nell'arco di 15 20 anni allo
sviluppo di una grave disabilità lo
scopo del mio lavoro è quello di
utilizzare le nuove immagini per capire
innanzitutto quali siano le alterazioni
cerebrali che hanno portato allo
sviluppo e alle manifestazioni cliniche
della malattia ma soprattutto per capire
quali sono i segni del cervello che ci
permettono di capire in maniera precoce
quindi sin dalle fasi iniziali della
malattia
quale sarà l'evoluzione clinica in quel
determinato paziente e quindi se questa
ragazza rientrerà in quel gruppo di
pazienti 5 su 10 che avranno un decorso
benigno o piuttosto svilupperà una grave
disabilità le malattie neurologiche oggi
rappresentano nel mondo una delle più
frequenti cause di disabilità
questo perché nonostante gli enormi
progressi delle neuroscienze soprattutto
negli ultimi decenni il cervello rimane
tuttora l'organo più complesso e che
sconosciuto del corpo umano per capire
la complessità del cervello umano basta
considerare un esperimento di
simulazione dell'attività cerebrale
umana che è stato fatto qualche anno fa
in giappone con un supercomputer uno dei
più potenti calcolatori al mondo questo
computer è riuscito a simulare un
secondo dell'attività cerebrale umana in
40 minuti quindi uno sforzo notevole per
ottenere un risultato tutto sommato
modesto
ecco questo ci da l'idea di quanto sia
complesso il cervello umano dell'adulto
infatti contiene circa 100 miliardi di
cellule neuronali ciascuna delle quali
può essere connesso a sua volta a
migliaia di altre cellule e attraverso
queste connessioni e circuiti il
cervello è in grado allo stesso tempo di
percepire analizzare interpretare
ridistribuire ma anche immagazzinare
informazioni di vario tipo
la conoscenza di tutti questi complessi
elementi è fondamentale per capire come
funziona il cervello della persona sana
ma anche nella patologia
noi possiamo riassumere tutti questi
aspetti in tre punti cardine che poi
sono il principale oggetto di studio
delle neuroscienze e delle neuroimmagini
e che sono quindi lo studio della
struttura del cervello delle sue
connessioni e della sua funzione
se le prime conoscenze dell'anatomia
macroscopica quindi della struttura del
cervello visibile ad occhio nudo
iniziano sin dall'antichità è soltanto
verso fine ottocento che un medico e
scienziato spagnolo santiago lamonica
utilizzando una nuova tecnica di
microscopia ottica che all'epoca era
stata messa a punto fisico italiano
camillo golgi riesce a fornire la prima
visualizzazione dei neuroni e delle loro
connessioni del cervello umano e anche
di altre specie animali
e così se all'epoca siamo fine 800 inizi
iniziano le neuroscienze moderne così
come la intendiamo noi oggi quindi con
lo studio della cellula neuronale come
unità strutturale funzionale di base del
cervello le tecniche di mappatura del
cervello in vivo nel paziente con
disturbi neurologici sono ancora molto
arretrate e non consentono una
visualizzazione diretta del cervello per
cui l'approccio al paziente neurologico
si basa soprattutto su l'esame clinico
quindi per esempio sulla valutazione
dello stato mentale rendimento della
coordinazione dei movimenti dei riflessi
della capacità di poter percepire
discriminare vari tipi di stimoli
sensoriali man esami neurologico a noi
fornisce soltanto una fotografia dello
stato attuale del paziente
un po come se fosse la scena finale di
un film di cui magari non conosciamo
nell'inizio nella trama e di cui quindi
non possiamo modificare il corso degli
eventi ma soltanto limitarci ad
osservare quella che è la scena finale
finale dobbiamo arrivare fino agli anni
70 per avere la prima visualizzazione
diretta in vivo di un cervello umano
ottenuta tramite la tomografia assiale
computerizzata quella che oggi noi
conosciamo comune mette come tac che
però come vediamo da queste immagini
fornisce ancora un'immagine piuttosto
grossolana della struttura cerebrale
la tac e le metodiche di tac sono
ovviamente progressivamente migliorate
nel tempo consentendo oggi di poter
visualizzare dei dettagli della
struttura del cervello che non erano
visibili delle prime scansioni degli
anni 70 era di fatto una tecnica che
viene utilizzata nello studio delle
alterazioni della struttura cerebrale
pazienti neurologici
ma sicuramente la metodica di noi
immagini che ha maggiormente
rivoluzionato l'approccio le
neuroscienze alla neurologia è la
presentata dalla risonanza magnetica
come dice il nome stesso è sono ansa
magnetica utilizzate campi magnetici e
non delle radiazioni come la carte per
cui si tratta di una tecnica
completamente innocua oggi abbiamo degli
apparecchi di risonanza magnetica ad
altissimo campo e con questi apparecchi
siamo riusciti ad ottenere la scansione
del cervello umano più dettagliata di
sempre per ottenere queste immagini che
quindi sono circa mille volte che
precise di una comune immagini di
risonanza magnetica ci sono volute circa
5 giorni
questo è stato possibile perché queste
immagini sono state ottenute su un
cervello post mortem di riscatto tra un
cadavere
ovviamente nella pratica clinica è
impossibile pensare di sottoporre i
pazienti a degli esami così lunghi
esistono però lì in vari centri del
mondo questi apparecchi risonanza
magnetica ad altissimo campo con i quali
sebbene ancora non siamo in grado di
vedere la cellula neuronale in vino però
possiamo vedere il cervello delle
risoluzioni altissime addirittura al di
sotto del millimetro
quindi questo modo noi possiamo studiare
delle alterazioni del tessuto cerebrale
che prima si potevano vedere soltanto
con la microscopia ottica delle tecniche
di naro patologia o istologia
sofisticate
per esempio della scala wsi multipla la
malattia di cui mi occupo noi con questi
apparecchi siamo in grado di vedere
delle piccolissime lesioni della
corteccia cerebrale che alla parte più
esterna del cervello dove risiedono le
cellule neuronali e da una struttura
estremamente sottile con uno spessore di
circa 2 3 mm
oggi noi abbiamo imparato che queste la
presenza di queste lesioni si associa
spesso un decorso benigno ea un accumulo
di disabilità ma quello che il neurologo
il nano scienziato ma che vogliono
sapere non è soltanto dove si
localizzano queste lesioni ma qual è
l'effetto di queste lesioni nella
struttura del cervello e nelle sue
connessioni
sappiamo infatti che il cervello è una
struttura costituita una fittissima rete
di connessioni di fibre neurali e forse
potremmo paragonare un po ad una
ragnatela in cui ci sono delle fibre di
diverso spessore che vanno in varie
direzioni magari si intersecano o si
organizzano in e fasci per stessi e la
rottura della ragnatela in un
determinato punto può provocare delle
alterazioni strutturali non soltanto nel
punto di rottura ma anche a distanza
e questo è un po quello che succede
anche nel cervello umano
oggi con la risonanza magnetica di
diffusione noi siamo in grado di
ottenere delle mappe più o meno
dettagliate di queste connessioni
basandoci principalmente sull'analisi
dei movimenti microscopici delle
molecole dell'acqua che si trovano in
questi tessuti la direzione di questi
movimenti non è una casuale ma viene
fortemente determinata dalla struttura e
dalla morfologia del tessuto in cui si
trovano per esempio i fasci di fibre
nervose sono caratterizzati dall'avere
una peculiare direzione con una
direzione preferenziale e questa viene
riflessa poi del movimento delle
molecole di acqua che si trovano
all'interno di queste fibre
questa caratteristica che noi chiamiamo
anisotropia può essere sfruttata con dei
modelli matematici per poter poi
ricostruire delle mappe tridimensionali
delle connessioni delle fibre neurali
all'interno del cervello
e come vedete qui si tratta di mappe
estremamente colorate in cui però il
ogni colore ha un significato ben
preciso cioè sta ad indicare la
direzione delle fibre e utilizzando
modelli matematici sempre più complessi
noi oggi siamo in grado non soltanto di
ottenere informazioni sulla direzione di
queste fibre ma che sulla loro struttura
quale sia il loro diametro spesso quanto
è spesso la tua stessa la guaina che le
riveste questi elementi sono molto
importanti per capire come processi
patologici di vario tipo per esempio un
tumore una lesione da sclerosi multipla
un trauma cranico possano alterare le
connessioni del cervello quindi se
soltanto nel luogo della lesione a
distanza se in maniera irreversibile o
reversibile
se queste lesioni sono in grado di
indurre delle modificazioni delle febbre
circostanti infatti contrariamente a
quanto si pensava fino agli anni ottanta
noi sappiamo oggi che il cervello è un
organo estremamente dinamico l'uno
chiamiamo plastico quindi in grado di
modificarsi continuamente nell'arco del
corso di tutta la vita in seguito a
stimoli ambientali o le lesioni che
possono colpirlo
questi fenomeni di modì in queste
modificazioni queste fenomeni vengono
chiamati i fenomeni di plasticità e
possono essere non soltanto di tipo
strutturale ma anche funzionale e molto
spesso i neurologi utilizzano questi
fenomeni di plasticità struttura le
funzioni del cervello per poter predire
quale sarà l'evoluzione clinica di un
determinato paziente o utilizzano questi
cambiamenti anche per monitorare
l'effetto di eventuali terapie
farmacologiche o di riabilitazione
se la risonanza magnetica di diffusione
rappresenta quindi uno strumento per
studiare quali sono le connessioni
all'interno del cervello e il loro
fenomeni di plasticità strutturale la
risonanza magnetica funzionale invece
rappresenta uno strumento per studiare
come funziona il cervello come si attiva
e quali possano essere eventuali
fenomeni di plasticità funzionale
indotti dal bari
i processi patologici questa tecnica non
misura attività neuronale direttamente
ma piuttosto indirettamente andando a
misurare le variazioni di insorge
ossigenazione e occorrono nei vasi
sanguini in un area in cui c'è un
attivazione delle cellule neuronali e
con questa tecnica noi oggi siamo in
grado di ottenere delle mappe di
attivazioni nelle più svariate
condizioni per esempio durante
l'esecuzione di compiti motori può
essere movimento della mano chiede
oppure durante teste di memoria o di
attenzione o anche durante condizioni
semplicemente passive magari qui
ascoltiamo un brano musicale o guardiamo
delle immagini è un aspetto interessante
che è emerso da questi studi di andatura
delle funzioni dei cervelli risonanza
magnetica funzionale è che anche quando
noi non siamo intenti a compiere uno
specifico compito o una specifica azione
per esempio quando noi torniamo dal
lavoro e magari stanchi ci sediamo su
una poltrona e cominciamo magari a
pensare cosa prepareremo per cena vino
verremo alla prossima vacanza da
programmare
ebbene anche in questi casi il cervello
è continuo lavoro e attira dei circuiti
cerebrali specifici che vengono chiamati
dei circuiti di default network che sono
proprio caratteristici delle fasi in cui
noi non siamo rivolti verso l'esterno
quindi a compiere una determinata azione
ma siamo piuttosto coinvolti in un
azione introspettiva magari sognano ad
occhi aperti oppure diciamo al passato o
pianifichiamo del futuro e degli studi
recenti sostengono che il corretto
funzionamento di questi circoli di
default la loro corretta la loro
integrità è fondamentale per preservare
un livello uno stato di coscienza
infatti la risonanza magnetica
funzionale quindi al riposo su alcuni di
questi circuiti di default e ma anche
durante stimoli rappresenta una delle
trova forse una delle sue applicazioni
più importanti e interessanti nello
studio dei pazienti con disturbi dello
stato di coscienza
secondaria gravi traumi cranici questo
perché noi sappiamo che in circa il 40
per cento di questi pazienti il semplice
tale clinico non è in grado di valutare
correttamente lo stato di coscienza
infatti alcuni anni fa alcuni
esperimenti di risonanza magnetica
funzionale in pazienti che clinicamente
avevano uno stato vegetativo persistente
o uno stato di minima coscienza
quindi non mostrano alcun segno
comportamentale di poter capire o
seguire quello che avveniva
dell'ambiente circostante
ebbene questi pazienti durante la
risonanza magnetica funzionale veniva
chiesto di girare di svolgere vari tipi
di movimento per esempio camminare
all'interno della loro casa pure a
giocare a tennis e questi studiano visto
che alcuni di questi pazienti non tutti
mostravano delle attivazioni nel
cervello in aree kong ue con il
movimento che loro immaginavano di fare
mostrando così di avere uno stato di
coscienza che invece non era
evidenziabile allo stato clinico questa
condizione oggi si chiama dissociazione
cognitivo motoria che è proprio per
l'esistenza di questa condizione oggi
reparti di terapia intensiva più
avanzati
la valutazione del paziente con gravi
traumi cranici non si basa più soltanto
sulle trame clinico ma viene anche
coadiuvata dall utilizzazione di queste
tecniche di massaggi dell'attività
cerebrale
quindi che possono essere a destra il
cefalo gramma con la risonanza magnetica
funzionale e qui vediamo per esempio il
caso di un paziente clinicamente
definito in stato vegetativo persistente
a seguito di una grave lesione contusiva
che qui vediamo rappresentata morara
bianca che mostra durante la risonanza
funzionale attivazione di varie aree che
sono congrue con il tasco il compito che
in quel momento che veniva richiesto
oggi con la disponibilità di magneti ad
altissimo campo che quindi ci permettono
di ottenere delle immagini del cervello
ad un'altissima risoluzione ma anche con
l'utilizzazione di software che
permettono di visualizzare al meglio la
corteccia cerebrale
noi siamo in grado di mappare l'attività
cerebrale umana con estrema precisione e
questo è mostrato qui questo esperimento
in cui ad un soggetto veniva mostrata la
lettera m
e con queste metodiche è stato in grado
di vedere nella corteccia visiva
primaria una mappa di attivazione
o la forma ad an questo esperimento è
stato ripetuto poi con varie lettere
precisamente quelle tre mgh che poi sono
delle iniziali del massachusetts general
hospital l'ospedale in cui sono stati
condotti questi esperimenti e ciascuna
lettera la visione di ciascuna di queste
lettere comportava l'attivazione della
corteccia visiva primaria con una mappa
che rappresentava la lettera stessa dal
momento che la corteccia visiva primaria
si attiva anche quando immaginiamo o
sogniamo quindi la possibilità di
leggere direttamente il cervello delle
persone con la risonanza magnetica
funzionale non appare più così lontana e
apre delle frontiere completamente nuove
non soltanto nell'ambito delle
neuroscienze o nell'ambito clinico
neurologico neuropsichiatrico ma anche
in campi che fino allora pensavo fossero
rispettati come per esempio il
management e marketing o anche in campo
legale